and there was a moment that got a lot of
attention today when one woman tried to
ask Pete a simple question
mayor Pete why did it take you an entire
two and a half weeks to actually get
here to respond to East Palestine will
you apologize to the residents of this
city can we ask why it took him almost
three weeks to get here I'm sorry I
don't want to do Clone Camera if you're
the Press Secretary of the secretary of
the Department of Transportation don't
you think you should be able to ask
questions from the American public that
absolutely I would like to do it without
the camera on can I ask I think that is
a little bit aggressive
I'd like to hear it without the camera
on joining me now is that aggressive
reporter you just saw Savannah Hernandez
TP USA front line reporter Savannah good
on you now that was Pete's press
secretary now she's fine when Pete is on
a bike and a bike lane telling us about
Transportation equity and all those
sorts of things electric buses
did she ever ask actually answer any of
your questions
absolutely not and again Pete
butterjudge running away from me and the
press secretary refusing to take any
questions is the perfect example of what
this entire Administration thinks about
the American people they run away they
try to hide when we ask for
accountability when we ask for them to
take responsibility and apologize for
the slow governmental response the
people here are some of the most kind
and loving and it's an absolute disgrace
that the federal government has
abandoned and ignored them now again
Laura I was also here yesterday and the
energy on the ground was incredible
because the people just wanted a leader
that would see them that would care
about them that would tell them that
they were not forgotten as American
citizens today the only people that were
on the ground were the approved press
but guess what I'm not approved press
and I never will be because I refuse to
ask pre-written questions and
pre-approved questions to the leaders we
need to be holding accountable and again
they have completely ignored these
people so shame on people to judge and
shame on his press secretary for not
being able to to answer questions on
camera she should probably read her job
description
well I understand they had some security
to shoe you away from him correct
oh yeah absolutely the security tried to
tell me that I couldn't film in a public
area and then for the first time in my
life in the United States I actually had
local police stand up for my right to
film in public and they told her she
could walk away and you know she ended
up doing so she actually spoke to
another reporter and guess what when
those cameras turned off she still
answered no questions
I mean for paternity Pete to follow
Donald Trump in East Palestine I mean I
almost feel sorry for him but then I
don't Savannah great job being there
today we really enjoyed it thanks so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else